hey guys Pete here is going to be my 10
things you might have missed in 20
season 3 episode 13 for the warning if
you haven't watched episode 13 please
stop watching now you've been warned a
little bit out of order I'm doing the 10
things video first and I've been digging
into all the theories and things around
some of the crazier parts of episode 13
so I figured I might as well just knock
this one out when I was looking at them
the first thing you might have missed is
this guy right here is credited as the
farm accountant in the credits he's an
interesting character because he looks
out of place so people were asking about
him in both the comments and on Twitter
and I just thought about it when I was
doing my second watch that it's kind of
a callback what he says he says you need
any money that's kind of funny because
you remember that evil coupe made a
point to say that he doesn't need
anything he wants things but the main
reason I put this guy in is because it
kind of led to the second one which is
the second thing you might have missed
is evil coupe is technically the boss of
the farm now like the whole process of
that scene if I'm saying do you need any
money and the other part where they give
him in his cell phones when he asks it
just dawned on me that whether he wanted
to be their boss or not he not only
defeated the boss that they had but he
killed him by punching him in the face
so basically everyone at that place now
have to do whatever evil coupe says
which should be kind of interesting
especially now that Richard Horne is
there as well
so yeah I mentioned that I like these
guys the look at these guys in the top
moments video but I also equally enjoy
the idea that he can get them to do
whatever he wants now that I thought of
it the third thing you might have missed
was the blue road tattoos that we see on
the girl who is crying at the Roadhouse
when James is singing her name was Renee
and a lot of people had commented on the
last video about her two tattoos there's
a road and there's a date that says six
seven sixty-three well it turns out that
this actress has both of these tattoos
so I think it's safe to say that the
date 6 7 63 doesn't mean anything
in relation to Twin Peaks unless they
wrote it in there after the fact she has
the tattoo because that's the date of
her grandparents anniversary the Rose on
the other hand they may have picked her
and casting because she had a rose
tattoo but he definitely had it already
she didn't get it for the filming
obviously and they also didn't like draw
it in or something it's just a regular
tattoo that she already had so I kind of
don't think that either one of these
things are important but there still
need to notice the fourth thing you
might have missed was that Sarah Palmer
scene was crazy
nowyou I'm sure you saw that but there's
a couple of things that stand out here
one is that she's drinking and that
there's two rabbits there by her
television a lot of people have made a
connection that that might be important
because David Lynch made a I don't know
was it a web series called rabbit that
starred Naomi Watts there's also the
callback to the rabbits that Hawk
mentioned when he's talking to Lucy and
Andy and then other people are pointed
out that it's a boxing match so maybe it
is Bushnell that she's watching I can't
really see what the connection would be
there but he is a boxer we know that the
fifth thing you might have missed is
also about Sarah and this is one that I
saw on Reddit yesterday I think predator
a Rick Ally X says that we what we all
noticed that it's looping right her
scene is looping there and people had
been connecting that to the idea that
the woodsman scene was looping as well
so this guy went back and he started
both of the exact same time and as it
turns out each sequence has the exact
same length so there's other similarity
Sara drinks once per sequence in the
loop and the woodsman would say drink
full once per sequence so this could
lead to a lot of speculation it could be
that she is the girl who had the ma Frog
crawl into her mouth although I've never
really made a lot of sense it could be
an indication that that is the case of
course the horse is a recurring symbol
and Sara's life and we did hear a horse
at the end of that sequence and then
woodsman in general she mentioned that
men were coming so there may be a
connection with her in that place but
you know like most of
things in this show that it's pretty
speculative all the way around
interesting to know that they're the
same length though for sure so that's a
good catch by a trocol IX the sex thing
you might have missed is in part
thirteen at the gas farm we see that Big
Ed has a bear while bears head more
specifically on his desk that says bear
with me and has a bell there that you
can ring to get his attention if he's
not in the room another editor zti
winterfell pointed out that Johnny's
bear has a body and no head so this is
probably not important at all but these
two images look hilarious side-by-side I
laughed when I saw them so tell me what
you think of anything that all me the
seventh one is also dealing with Big Ed
and I saw something about this on
Twitter first and then it came up on
reddit later it appears that Ed's
reflection doesn't match up with what
he's doing ignoring that scene now
Spartan 0 for 8 on reddit posted the
video and I've lost it a bunch of times
and I really don't know how to describe
it better than that except where it's
not the same you should really actually
watch it yourself to see what I mean
because you kind of see him looking at
himself or his reflection and it looks
like it picks up the cup of soup
whenever he's not doing that it doesn't
it doesn't last but for a couple seconds
but you can see it if you watch it
closely the 8th thing you might have
missed is that nothing into furniture in
the room that Audrey and Charlie are in
looks to be modern none of it is new
like that's not like a collection of
older new things it really all looks to
be like mid 20th century so that's
interesting I mentioned it in the top
moments video that it's starting to get
harder to imagine that everything's okay
wherever Audrey is or whatever's going
on with her and I was reading that I was
reading Alexandra Bond X Times article
on the episode and she was talking about
a play called no exit where the cast is
stuck in hell and are unable to find
their way out of the room that they
share that's sort of how things were
going for her like she wants to read but
she can't she doesn't know how far away
the Roadhouse is
Charlie even said something about like
the end of her story so something seems
wrong I also mentioned that there are
several theories going around with the
most popular being that she is still in
a coma that she got into after that Bank
explosion there's other ones that are
like she might have brain damage she
could be in therapy and Charlie could be
her therapist one that she's dead and
she's in some sort of transitional space
or hell or something like that purgatory
so yeah there's a lot of things out
there so let me know what you guys think
about that in the comments because I
think it's getting more and more obvious
that she's not in present time twin
peaks'
trying to head out to the Roadhouse like
the conversation is going the nice one
is all about time and a lot of people
pointed this out Bobby enters the Double
R he's talking to Big Ed and Norma and
he says well we found some stuff that my
dad left today right away that set off
alarm bells for a lot of people because
that seems to be out of time with other
things that we see if that is the case
and it's not a continuity error then
this would be hard evidence that the
timeline is out of order and that's to
say if he's actually talking about the
to the metal tubes that he that they
found it's very possible they could have
found something else but I get it I get
why people are bringing this up because
it does seem like the implication is
more likely that time is not in order so
it's very confusing to me that's why I
don't really offer an answer one way or
another when it comes down to stuff like
this you know people can prove it one
way or the other based on their
observation so yeah there's people out
there they're saying that it's very
clear there is a timeline up on reddit
but then there's also people making good
arguments for it not being as well so
you know what I mean we're gonna have to
wait and see I am NOT ready to pass
judgment I mean I think there probably
is some things that are out of order but
I can't tell you more than what we just
saw in this scene like you know some
some weird things have happened but I
haven't organized them all to deliver it
in that way and the 10th thing you might
have missed was the ring and the
Dutchman I mean obviously you didn't
miss the ring but
seems that the intent as we could tell
was to get evil to back into the Red
Room ray says someone he didn't
recognize the Guardian recognized bran
the ring while they're in jail he wanted
this to go down that way because there's
something inside of you that they want
so to plural and then he asked him where
Jeffries is and he says he's at the
Dutchman so one of the things I saw
about that was maybe this is a reference
to the Flying Dutchman which is a ghost
ship that can never dock you know sort
of supposed to be like eternally doomed
to travel between worlds kind of thing
but the thing that stands out to me
about this is if there's one ring and it
was kind of implied that there was as
Mike put it back in the exact same place
there does this mean that Jefferies is
working with Mike or does it mean that
Mike is impersonating Jeff doesn't mean
Mike's related at all can anyone take
the ring and then it just always comes
back whenever someone's wearing it I
don't really know definitely a cool
episode I think I think I did experience
a little bit of fatigue here though like
I like the way that this one started out
after the last one sort of ended slowly
but then this one kind of did the same
thing and while it was mysterious I'm
hoping that the next episode will be
another pick up episode where a lot of
stuff happens because I don't think that
well what's the way out of scar I don't
think it feels right at this point of
course Audrey and Sarah are important
characters here but I would like to see
that their mysteries kind of move closer
to being solved rather than drifting in
different directions so we're going to
have to wait and see what happens please
like the video if you enjoyed it make
sure you subscribe to my channel if you
have not yet make sure you check out my
other videos and hit the subscription
notifications thing after you subscribe
so you know when a new video comes out
definitely let me know what you're
thinking about in the comments follow me
on Twitter Instagram and Facebook thanks
for watching guys I'll talk to you soon